one of the most popular documentaries
most talked-about documentaries that's
been out in the last couple of months is
this fire festival documentary and you
make this cameo at the end of the
documentary as the sort of moral voice
at the very end let's take a look this
morning the organizers of the failed
fire festival are feeling the heat we
took a big jump here and a big risk in
v1 has failed people were making fun of
it making fun of us do you feel bad for
the people that did spend money and go
to this if you had thousands of dollars
the goat on a trip to see blink 182
that's on you that is Darwinism that is
fine
I was just watching the documentary with
anyone else like anyone else and and
then that came up at the end I was like
I wonder if Ron is hearing you must be
hearing from a lot of people of tweets
about it people telling me about it I
didn't know I was in it I was lucky I
was wearing a shirt with my name on it
like I usually do the same person that
was smart that was I got all these these
these Twitter notifications all these
DMS and so then I called my manager and
I was like do I get any money from this
and she was like no it's from the fair
you second I was like this damn vest
will screw in everybody know you're the
final victim of the Billy mix work if
you want to start a Kickstarter for me
you probably got too much time on your
head